hi my name is Carl Rosen I'm a software
engineer working on Android I worked on
the application framework and the lock
screen one of the things I love about
Android is the gesture based on lock
screen when you turn your screen on you
press menu to get to your unlock screen
and which you draw a pattern to get past
it
in this case I have a simple pattern set
but if I wanted to create a more complex
pattern I could easily go to my security
settings change the lock pattern confirm
my existing one and now choose something
a little bit more tricky confirm that
done now when I turn off the screen I
will be required to draw my new more
complex pattern